président faut aller vous coucher
maintenant oui je vais y aller parce que
j'ai l'âge de l'enfant rentré pour vous
laisser faire la fête entre jeunes
possible un tel souci et or ceci étant
vous savez dans le domaine de l'âge je
vous dire deux choses
j'ai connu mois des petits vieux de 20
ans des pointes de 35 et 40 ans qui
faisait leur petite carrière vous savez
c'est incroyable moi je n'ai aucun plan
de carrière
et puis je me suis rendu compte qu'on
pouvait être jeune encore très tard et
puis l'autre jour je voyais le président
chirac et je lui disais vous êtes en
bonne santé vous dis oui ça va oui vous
avez l'air jeune je dis oui j'ai six
mois de moins que vous et puis françois
mitterrand m'avait enseigné aussi une
chose il me dit vous savez la vie
commence à 70 ans aurait encore beaucoup
de temps devant moi
[Musique]